Limón en el Tomás es una de las ciudades
donde se ha Librado de las grandes
batallas en esta región ya en mayo las
tropas rusas libraron una gran pelea por
tomar el control de esta ciudad que
volvió a estar en poder de las tropas
ucranianas durante la ofensiva no
solamente en la región de harquip sino
hacia el sur en el mes de octubre hoy la
ciudad está en control de las tropas
ucranianas pero la destrucción es
absolutamente grande tal vez una de las
mayores que hemos visto en muchas
ciudades de esta parte de Ucrania aquí
nos cuentan que de 42 mil personas que
vivían hay Apenas 6.000 muchas de ellas
viven en viviendas que están
prácticamente dañadas o tienen las
ventanas rotas muchos de ellos
sobreviven con unos pequeños
calentadores de leña y otros tienen que
vivir todavía en sótanos porque sus
casas no están en condiciones para para
vivir sin embargo muchos de ellos o por
los pocos que se ven en las calles que
hemos conversado dicen que esta es
Ucrania y que ellos se van a quedar aquí
a pesar de que los bombardeos están muy
cerca Un par de kilómetros de aquí está
línea de enfrentamiento de la
contraofensiva ucraniana y también de
los rusos están tratando de venir otra
vez a tomar el control de esta zona Así
que hay bombardeos todo el tiempo hemos
visto entrar muchos heridos a la ciudad
y nos sigue no es una zona estable Pero
ellos dicen o por lo menos los que están
aquí que se van a quedar sin embargo la
destrucción es bastante grande Esta es
una ciudad bastante estratégica porque
de aquí pueden
pelear para controlar otra gran parte
del Don vas especialmente la ciudad de
eslovens